[Musique]
Véronique prince Michel David Jonathan
Trudeau bonsoir
bonsoir grosse journée Véronique vous
avez votre compte-rendu impeccable tout
à l'heure beaucoup beaucoup de chiffres
mais le nommait pas tant justement vous
êtes allés à l'essentiel puissance parce
que on a une pile grosse demain
j'exagère Paul
avec vous puis mon bureau je préfère une
usine de recyclage de papier tellement
que j'ai du papier mais bon baisse
d'impôts tel que promis c'est exactement
ce qu'on avait promis ce qu'on fait un
point de pourcentage pour les deux
premiers paliers on va écouter le
ministre on vient tout de suite
je suis fier d'annoncer l'une des plus
importantes baisse d'impôts de
l'histoire du Québec j'annonce que les
deux premiers taux d'imposition seront
réduits de 1 point de pourcentage dès
cette année cette baisse d'impôts
totalisera 9,2 milliards de dollars
d'ici 2027 2028 et bénéficiera à 4.6
millions de Québécois si on avait pas eu
de baisse d'impôts nous aurions réduit
de 7 et demi pour cent la dette nette
sur 10 ans et là on va le faire sur 15
ans mais il y a des bénéfices par contre
c'est qu'on va réduire le fardeau fiscal
des Québécois qui est le plus élevé en
Amérique du Nord et surtout on voler
parce que contrairement à ce qu'il est
parfois véhiculé c'est les citoyens
ordinaires qui paient beaucoup plus
d'impôts en Ontario
alors la dette prendra un peu plus de
temps non pas assez facile complètement
mais à réduire
Véronique prince mais c'était clair ça
écrit qu'il fallait qu'il tienne
promesse et en plus ils y croient le
c'est pas comme si ils se forçaient
ouais en fait moi ce que je trouve la
première vue parce que par où commencer
quand on doit parler d'un budget qui
était comme ça comme je vous disais là
mais moi ce que je constate c'est que
toutes les cases sont cochées en matière
de promesses électorale c'est comme si
François Legault avait dit à Éric Girard
regarde ma plateforme électorale
assure-toi que tout soit dedans parce
que François Legault lui ce qu'il aime
c'est qu'on dise de lui que c'est un
Premier ministre qui livre la
marchandise et donc dès le premier
budget fallait que les promesses
électorales soient dedans et la promesse
fort c'était justement c'est baisse
d'impôts là alors on n'a pas de surprise
c'est pratiquement à quelques détails
près la même chose qu'on retrouvait
justement dans la plateforme électorale
je dirais peut-être que j'imagine que
vous allez peut-être vouloir y revenir
mais là où je trouve qu'il prête flan
peut-être plus à la critique c'est en
matière de logement alors qu'on a une
crise importante partout au Québec ce
sont en y reviendra mais c'est vraiment
à ce niveau là où il semble être un
petit peu plus à découvert parce que
c'est peut-être pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'on s'attendait en terme
d'investissement d'ailleurs je à la
Régie si on peut avoir les extraits de
la Ville de Montréal et de la ville de
Québec ils sont pas très contents sur le
logement là aujourd'hui mais restons sur
les baisses d'impôts Michel c'est et
Jonathan c'est quand même le gros
morceau
il a aussi un capital de sympathie
énorme le gouvernement est populaire
et eux sont convaincus que c'est une
mesure qui va les rendre encore plus
populaire Michel
bah oui écoutez il y a personne qui
refuse une baisse d'impôts mais la
question est pas de savoir si les gens
sont contents c'est de savoir si c'est
responsable monsieur
Gérard dit mon budget est prudent et
responsable moi personnellement je le
trouve un peu hasardeux dans la mesure
où lui-même reconnaît qu'il y a 50% de
chances de riz session avec tout ce que
ça implique ça sera peut-être pas une
récession majeure mais il reste que le
propre des récession c'est d'augmenter
les obligations des gouvernements et je
comprends que les baisses d'impôts vont
être financés à même une réduction des
cotisations au fond des générations mais
il reste que c'est de l'argent qu'il y
aurait pu aller chercher pour faire
autre chose si le besoin s'en était fait
sentir alors on regarde les prévisions
de dépenses par exemple en santé cette
année tout est beau le gouvernement
profite de l'inflation pour augmenter
ses revenus on augmente les dépenses de
santé de 7% dès l'an prochain ça tombe à
deux points 1 pour cent deux points pour
cent là c'est pas même la moitié de ce
qu'on appelle l'écoute système c'est à
dire l'argent il faut mettre dedans pour
maintenir la qualité du réseau au même
niveau
qui va falloir l'an prochain pour ne pas
diminuer les services et tout ça au
moment où Monsieur Dubé le ministre de
la Santé nous annonce un plan de
fondation qui va inévitablement coûter
des sous alors là le gouvernement est
content les contribuables sont contents
mais on verra ce qu'ils vont dire l'an
prochain ou dans deux ans Jonathan
on est ici pour faire de l'analyse par
contre qui est différente lorniettes
qu'on peut utiliser pour analyser un
budget comme celui-là il y a tout
d'abord l'angle économique si on veut ça
pour ça je vais laisser le soin aux
spécialistes qui s'y connaissent de de
regarder le fait des détails à savoir si
fiscalement par exemple c'est
responsable d'être allé de l'avant
deuxième lorgnac celle de l'analyse
politique qu'est-ce qu'on est ici on a
un gouvernement qui avait évoqué ces
baisses d'impôts là avant l'élection qui
les a annoncé en campagne électorale et
qui vient les confirmer aujourd'hui donc
d'un strict point de vue politique c'est
un gouvernement qui remplit ses
engagements et la troisième lorgnette
j'ai envie de de dire que c'est celle du
contribuable celui du père de taxe qui
depuis des mois et des mois voient les
factures s'empiler les taux d'intérêt
augmenter l'inflation qui qui fait son
œuvre et qui dit mais vous savez quoi la
bouffée d'oxygène on en avait bien
besoin donc en ce sens-là je comprends
qu'il peut y avoir des certaines
réserves pour pour les économistes et je
remets poisson en question mais sur deux
aspects bien clairs je pense que sur ce
point-là notre gouvernement qui livre la
marchandise vous dites c'est coché que
oui parce que le contexte a changé
évidemment depuis un an et demi le
contexte économique avec l'inflation
avec le ralentissement et lui-même le
dit un Véronique vous l'avez dit il dit
c'est 55 ans Québec peut retomber
peut-on tomber c'est à dire en récession
mais je crois encore que 50% de chances
que quand qu'on sorte la tête de l'eau
ce qui est intéressant c'est que il y a
deux scénarios alternatifs un scénario
ou justement l'économie va très mal on
tombe en récession puis à ce moment-là
il y a un coussin financier dans lequel
on va piger c'est-à-dire une provision
annuelle de virgule 5 milliards de
dollars puis d'un autre côté là c'est le
scénario optimiste oh là ça va beaucoup
mieux que ce qu'on s'attend puis
finalement mais le retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire qui est prévu pour 2027 2028
va peut-être qu'on va être capable de
l'amener plus proche donc il y a ces
deux scénarios là puis moi j'ai demandé
au ministre Girard vous êtes plus proche
de quel scénario vous dites c'est 50-50
le masque vous penchez plus vers l'un
vers l'autre et il répondait il y a 10
jours j'aurais penché pour le scénario
optimiste il y a 10 jours aujourd'hui
peut-être moins c'est pour vous dire à
quel point l'économie fluctue comme ça
du jour au lendemain puis probablement
que dans sa tête il pensait aussi à tout
ce qui s'était passé ce qui s'était
passé avec les banques aux États-Unis en
Suisse et tout ça alors oui Michel en a
parlé dépense en santé qui augmente de
7,7 c'est beaucoup presque 60 milliards
je le dis en passant c'est la moitié du
budget du Québec en santé éducation 6%,
il y a des ordres ministères qui vont
devoir se serrer la ceinture en fait
tous les autres enseignement supérieur
monte également est-ce que là
politiquement et avec l'argent qu'ils
ont sur la table les ministres du B et
drinville ont ce qu'il faut Jonathan
ça ça va être intéressant de constater
parce que dans les dernières dernières
semaines on entendait souvent soit bon
Christian Dubé Bernard drinville ou
encore la présidente du Conseil du
Trésor Sonia Lebel dire que on devait
avoir les moyens de nous de nos
ambitions ce serait hasardeux pour pour
moi de vous dire ben écoutez je pense
que là avec 7,7 % santé 6 % d'éducation
ils vont avoir suffisamment les moyens
pour augmenter par exemple les salaires
à des niveaux qui vont permettre la
rétention qui vont permettre le retour
ou de convaincre des gens de de
s'investir en santé en éducation mais
chose est certaine c'est qu'il y a des
sommes colossales qui sont annoncées
reste à voir comment ce sera réparti
comment ce sera dénoncé et si j'étais un
petit bémol Michel Le Bien évoqué tantôt
c'est qu'on voit que rapidement ces
sommes là vont être beaucoup plus
réduites du 2%, 3% à partir de 2024 2025
donc est-ce que le la joue l'influx
supplémentaire dès 2023 sera suffisant
et aura pas besoin d'être bonifié au fil
des années on verra parce qu'on sait il
y a rien qui change plus facilement
qu'un budget des prévisions sur le sur
les autres années mais je pense qu'on
devrait garder garder l’œil là-dessus
mon gouvernement on dit que on veut
envoyer le signal qu'on va vouloir aussi
contrôler quand même l'augmentation des
dépenses à partir de 2024 2025 vous vous
Michel vous avez dit c'est comme si on
disait on veut pas froid tout de suite
ce qui va arriver mais cette année on
est conscient qu'il faut monter mais on
verra on pousse un peu à part en aval
oui et puis il y a un gros point
d'interrogation qui qui plane au dessus
de tout ça tant pour le ministère de la
Santé que de l'éducation c'est la
question de la main-d'oeuvre là on est
en train de négociation dans le secteur
public
tous les beaux plans là qu'on peut
échafauder le repose sur la possibilité
d'aller chercher la main d'oeuvre
disponible ce soit des enseignants des
infirmières des préposés des éducatrices
et là on a une situation où à partir de
l'an prochain
l'argent va être moins va être plus rare
les conventions collectives c'est pas
juste pour une année il faut que le
gouvernement prévoit qui va payer ces
gens-là pendant les trois prochaines
années alors les augmentations ne
peuvent qu'être limitées si la
croissance des dépenses des revenus
lettent aussi alors seul le gouvernement
doit tenir compte de ça et ma crainte
c'est que les négociations achoppent en
partie pour des raisons budgétaires le
gouvernement voudra pas et ses
responsable s'engager engagés de
l'argent qui n'est pas sûr d'avoir et
d'ailleurs vous avez raison de souligner
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre par la bande
parce que les ce qu'on annonce comme
changement au régime des rentes du
Québec c'est pour permettre précisément
des gens de rester sur le marché du
travail plus longtemps là c'est c'est
plus technique là c'est moins c'est
moins l'analyse politique mais je le
mets en passant le tableau c'est très
important ça Véronique aujourd'hui parce
qu'on a enlevé des irritants qui qui
faisait en sorte que des gens disaient
je vais rester à la maison c'est pas
payant les travailler là c'est sûr que
le gouvernement mise beaucoup sur ce
qu'on appelle les travailleurs
expérimentés là pour qu'il reste au
travail donc c'est ça on leur donne
plusieurs incitatifs mais d'un autre
côté j'ai été quand même étonné de voir
que les ministères de l'emploi de
l'économie
recevait un budget en fait leur budget
étant amputé c'est tantôt disait il y a
beaucoup de ministères qui auront pas du
tout le même budget ça augmente en santé
puis en éducation mais tous les autres
vont avoir une amputation de leur budget
justement dans les budgets précédents
avec la pandémie rappelez-vous ceux qui
obtenaient la part du lion c'était
justement emploi solidarité sociale
économie parce que on rentrait la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre là-dedans puis
on y allait à coup de millions même un
coup de milliards pour essayer de garder
les gens d'emploi ou d'amener même des
nouvelles personnes donc je vous avoue
que on n'a pas fini de l'étudier le
budget parce que tellement une piste de
Gérald on en a parlé tout à l'heure je
vous donne une piste c'est que dans ce
ministère là il y avait le budget des
chèques ponctuels qui ne seront plus là
donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a un
fléchissement mais vous avez raison n'a
pas fini de l'étudier je vais vous faire
entendre le maire de Québec qui
et à Montréal aussi on a des réactions
où on se dit sur le logement social
entre autres gros point d'interrogation
on écoute c'est très court le meilleur
marchand puis on revient tout de suite
par rapport au logement social donc nous
sommes en attente la ventilation des
unités Québec la ville le Québec a
besoin de 500 unités par année c'est le
minimum qu'on a besoin pour faire face à
la crise du logement dans lequel nous
sommes alors comment vont être ventilé
on va attendre du gouvernement mais
notre demande ne change pas et on
s'attend à avoir les réponses à nos
questions
même chose même son de cloche Jonathan
du côté de Québec de Montréal
pardonnez-moi à tour de table il y a des
il y a des gens qui ont été déçus quand
même cet après-midi là
absolument parce que on sait que le
besoin il est criant il est urgent et
des fois on s'explique un peu mal cette
cette réticence certains diront ouais
mais ils l'ont reconnu mais c'est un peu
tardif on sent pas que c'est dans les
priorités nécessaires même du
gouvernement d'améliorer l'offre de de
logement location ceci étant dit je
garde en tête que popstar qui a quelques
semaines l'un de mémoire c'est autour du
20 février on apprenait que c'était quoi
le tiers seulement des logements qui
avaient été annoncés qui étaient
effectivement construit donc moi je veux
bien qu'on annonce des milliers des
milliers de nouveaux logements sociaux
de les construire et semble-t-il que
souvent c'est difficile et je suis pas
en train de dire que le gouvernement pas
une part de responsabilité là-dedans la
lourdeur administrative les processus et
autres mais il reste que un peu comme
des places en garderie des fois on en
annonce on en annonce on fait de la
surenchère mais on se rend compte que
finalement le rythme de de de mise en
chantier et très très lent donc est-ce
qu'ils auraient eu les moyens c'est de
leurs ambitions c'est une question qu'on
peut se poser est-ce que Michel et Véron
parce qu'il y a des selon vous des
faiblesses évidentes quand vous avez vu
les réactions là au huis clos par
exemple Michel
vous l'avez dit tantôt forcément à
partir du moment où on met le paquet sur
la santé et l'éducation avec l'argent
pose pas dans les arbres inévitablement
il y a des missions disons qui qui vont
être moins bien servis on parle du
logement mais je pourrais ajouter et ça
doit être une préoccupation pour les
villes les grandes villes en particulier
ces jours-ci il y a pas beaucoup
d'argent qui consacré à la lutte contre
la violence et même pour la santé
mentale dont on parle abondamment ces
jours-ci c'est pas beaucoup d'argent
quand on vend-il par année qui est
consacré à ça alors
les comment dire les drames à répétition
auxquelles on assiste cette année
il faut s'y attaquer et ça ça passe par
des budgets en santé mentale mais aussi
en prévention de la violence et là je
pense que les intervenants dans ces
secteurs-là vont pointer le budget du
droit en disant hey réveillez-vous
est-ce que en deux mots
Véronique il y a des angles morts
le logement je vais revenir à ça parce
que moi ce que je vois c'est seulement
1500 nouveaux logements on en annonce
des milliers mais quand on décortique ça
en fait c'est plus la rénovation que de
nouvelles unités en tant que tel qu'il
faut faire attention aussi parce que
dans le passé il y a beaucoup d'annonces
qui ont été faites et refaites et
refaites mais annoncer tout le temps de
manière un peu différente mais
finalement c'est un peu la même chose là
donc pas beaucoup de nouveaux logements
pendant que vous étiez au huis clos
Véronique et Michel
changement de cap Ottawa madame tellfeu
de Cathy tellfred chef de cabinet de
Monsieur Trudeau ira finalement témoigné
à ce comité qui se penche sur
l'ingérence étrangère notamment chinoise
petit extrait Ottawa bon vient tout de
suite
finalement raté la camouflage et
déclencher un enquête publique dès
aujourd'hui pourquoi ne pas appeler une
enquête publique indépendante dans le
commissaire sera nommé par cette chambre
des gens
verrez des gens méritent une enquête
publique parce que l'ingérence étrangère
nuit à la confiance de notre démocratie
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place un
rapporteur indépendant en monsieur
Johnson qui va pouvoir creuser au fond
des choses de façon indépendante et non
partisans y compris avec une enquête
publique s'il décide que s'il est
nécessaire
alors qu'a dit talfu témoigne parce que
le NPD allait voter avec les
conservateurs et le bloc une motion
déconservateurs à la Chambre des
communes pour dénoncer le fait qu'elle
ne témoignait pas donc libéraux ont dit
bon mais très bien Jonathan
est-ce que le paravent Johnson est
suffisant à Monsieur Trudeau pour les
prochains pour les prochains jours
faudra voir parce que le Davy Johnston
va faire des recommandations Justin
Trudeau qui s'engage à suivre ces
recommandations là mais ça va prendre un
certain temps mais au niveau de l'ajout
de politique c'est vraiment pas anodin
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui pour le
bénéfice des gens peut-être un peu moins
familiers lorsqu'on parle de la chef de
cabinet du premier ministre du Canada
c'est la numéro 2 du gouvernement une
chef de cabinet d'un Premier ministre a
souvent même
normalement plus de pouvoir d'influence
que l'ensemble du conseil des ministres
donc c'est pour rien de réussir à la
faire témoigner en commission ce que je
m'explique toujours mal lorsque vient le
temps d'analyser les décisions du
gouvernement Trudeau c'est qu'on a
l'impression qu'il marche pas avec le
même calendrier que nous ça fait deux
trois semaines que cette décision là
aurait dû être prise il vient un moment
où le flair politique devrait te dicter
que si une décision qui te fait pas
plaisir mais qui va finir par s'imposer
tu es aussi bien de la prendre plus près
même si c'était déjà évoqué il y a
quelques semaines dans les officines au
gouvernement disait peut-être que Madame
tellefeuille ont prêté à quel témoin
encore une fois sur une décision qui
vient très très tard avec un Premier
ministre qui disait vous savez pourquoi
pas vous dire grand-chose ça aide pas à
calmer les suspicions que tout un chacun
peuvent avoir à commencer par leurs
adversaires politiques évidemment comme
si Michel on veut on attendait que
l'élastique soit prêt à éclater là bah
oui exactement alors que dans le fond la
comparution de Madame talford d'un point
de vue gouvernemental dépendant de ce
que veut dire mais en admettant que elle
donne les bonnes réponses
ça peut être avantageux dans la mesure
où il faut trouver des raisons de ne pas
tenir cette enquête publique là d'un
point de vue gouvernemental alors si on
donne toujours l'impression d'avoir des
choses à cacher on renforce l'envie
d'une commission si madame talford
commence à expliquer un certain nombre
de choses et que les gens disent ouais
bon c'est une explication qui se tient
déjà la pression va peut-être diminuer
un peu il y a un risque mais je pense
qu'actuellement on pourrait où on en est
le gouvernement Trudeau là doit tout
faire pour pour faire montrer la
pression choisir la transparence vers un
équat
effectivement je suis d'accord que c'est
pas anodin c'est le bras droit mais en
mettant ça nous laisse toujours un peu
sur notre fin ce genre de témoignage là
et déjà je serai Trudeau à vertical pour
pas tout dire toute donner les réponses
aux questions donc déjà il nous donne un
avertissement je sais pas à quel point
on va apprendre beaucoup de choses
importantes avoir merci beaucoup à vous
trois Véronique Michel Jonathan très
bientôt bonne soirée bonne soirée pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI